hi i'm beau carnes with free code camp
in this course i will teach you how to
create a very simplified heroku clone
this course is really all about how to
provision infrastructure
programmatically heroku is a platform as
a service that allows developers to
build run and operate applications
entirely in the cloud heroku makes it
easy to do things such as deploy virtual
machines to host applications and to
deploy websites into the cloud some of
the things that heroku offers can
actually be done pretty easily with
other tools in this course i will teach
you how to develop a simple web app that
will allow users to provision virtual
machines and deploy static web apps
all at the click of a button and hosted
on amazon web services
so this is what the heroku clone is
going to look like like i mentioned it's
very simplified it just has two options
to
deploy your own static website or set up
a virtual machine for development and
testing so let me just show you what
this looks like
so you're here and it's going to show a
list of the sites these are ones that
have already been created we can also
create a new site where you can put in
the name and then you can put in a url
where it'll get that html code right
from that url or you can type in your
own html and then when you click create
it will create that site it'll deploy it
right to aws
and then i'll tell you about what some
of these like the view and console tell
you about that later in the actual
course
but and then clicking the links here
will actually open up the sites again
you'll see that more in the actual
course let me just show you what it
looks like when you create the virtual
machine
so here we can create a virtual machine
and then you can create choose the
instance type
and with the virtual machine you're
always going to have a public key this
is a way that it can be authenticated
after you after the virtual machine is
deployed to aws
we can ssh into that but we need to
authenticate it with our private key so
those are all the features you're going
to be able to deploy and destroy delete
the these things right from aws so right
from this web interface we'll be able to
create the virtual machine on the site
and also we can delete the virtual
machines and the websites all from our
web interface we don't even have to log
into aws to do any of that stuff
and then also i'll show you how to make
a javascript version of one section of
this at the very end of the course
provisioning infrastructure is related
to platform engineering
a platform engineering team serves an
organization by planning designing and
managing its cloud platforms and often
this can be done programmatically
the tools i teach in this course can be
used for much more than just
provisioning vms and deploying websites
they can be used for platform
engineering to make it simpler to manage
cloud platforms
this course focuses on the automation
api from pollumi
paloomi provided free codecamp a grant
that made this course possible
pollumi's open source infrastructure as
code stk allows you to create deploy and
manage infrastructure on any cloud using
a variety of programming languages their
automation api makes it possible to
provision infrastructure
programmatically using the pollumi
engine
basically it makes it simple to write a
program that automatically creates vms
databases vpcs static websites and more
on a variety of different cloud
platforms
i'm going to show you how to create our
heroku clone web app using flask and
python on the back end
however you don't already have to know
how to use flask and python to follow
along
also everything i show you could also be
done with many other different
frameworks and programming languages
and many of the steps are the same no
matter what web framework you use our
app will provision resources on aws but
pollumi makes it simple to provision
resources on most of the major cloud
providers and it wouldn't take that much
updating to the code to use a different
provider thanks to kamal ali who created
the code that my code in this course is
based off of
so let's start making the application by
the way at the end i'll also show you
how to use the automation api to
provision infrastructure using
javascript so you can see how it's
different between javascript and python
and also see how it's very similar so
let's start setting everything up i've
already created a directory on my
computer called
herokul
which is where we're going to be
creating the project
we first need to make sure that we have
the plumi cli installed
the way to install is different
depending on your operating system
if you have mac os you can just do brew
install
pollumi
and if you have windows you can do
choco install
pallumi
both those assume that you either have
home brew or chocolaty installed
check the link in the description for
other ways of installing pollumi
now this project also uses aws so you'll
have to make sure you have an aws
account and you have the cli set up and
authenticated
you can sign up for a free aws account
at the link in
i have a link in the description that
will show you how to sign up for a free
aws account
and then there's another link that shows
you how to install the aws cli
it's going to be different depending on
your operating system
once you have the aws cli installed you
can configure it by just doing aws
configure
and then the first thing you're going to
have to do is put in your aw access key
again i'm going to put a link in the
description to how you do that because
amazon has some very specific
instructions on how to get an aws access
key but once you have the access key you
can enter it you can enter the secret
access key and then you can choose your
default region name
i'm just going to keep it as the default
here which is aws the us region 2
default output format you may just want
to keep all those the same
and
after that's configured it's time to set
up the paloomi project
a plumi project is just a directory with
some files in it
it's possible for you to create a new
one by hand or you can use the plumy new
command so that's what we're going to do
do paloomy
new this is using the plumy cli
okay says please choose a template or
mine does if this is the first time
you've used polumi you'll be directed to
enter an access code or log in
so it's going to give you a url to go to
and you may have to make a plumi account
but once you enter the access code
you'll see this where it says please
choose a template
so we're going to choose aws
python we're going to be creating a
python app that hosts resources on aws
and then we can choose things like the
project name i'm going to do hero cool
okay it looks like it doesn't exist
because i've already it's associated
with my pollumi account and i've already
created a project with that name for a
test so i'm going to create a another
i'm going to just call it something else
even though we know that it's supposed
to be called hero cool so how about row
cool
2
okay and then you can just
pick the defaults for this
stack i'm going to keep the default it's
going to initialize into a new stack
called dev which is an instance of our
project
every plumi program is deployed to a
stack a stack is an isolated
independently configurable instance of a
plumi program stacks are commonly used
to denote different phases of
development in this case we're using dev
so i'm just going to use that
and then
we can choose the aws region to imp to
deploy to now keep in mind this is
actually different than the default we
said before and this is the one that's
actually going to be used us east one
and now you can see it's creating the
virtual environment
okay installed a bunch of libraries
we're going to need into our virtual
environment but we're going to need a
few more so i'm going to do
so first i'll just list here you can see
we created the plumi.yaml file that's
used to
configure everything the main.pi file
which is where our main python code is
going to go
the requirements.txt
which tells us our dependencies and then
the vnv directory this is our virtual
environment
and we are going to
run
a program in the virtual environment so
normally when you're installing python
dependencies you use the program pip but
i'm going to make sure to
run the program pip from our virtual
environment so i'm going to do vnv dot
slash bin slash
pip
and then i'm going to install
flask
and
requests
so these are two
dependencies so we were making a flask
app and the requests library will allow
us to make
http requests so
after we get everything installed in our
terminal
i'm going to open up this folder
in visual studio code
okay so here's everything in visual
studio code it has all the files i
mentioned such as our configuration file
plumi.yaml the requirements and then the
main.pi this is where our main python
code is going to go and you can see it
installed some
it put in some default code here we're
going to end up changing most of this
so we're going to start off by actually
changing the name of this file to
app.pi uh it's common for
flask to be to be looking for a file
called app.pi
for the flask app so like i said we're
gonna get rid of this code we're going
to eventually use some code similar to
this but for now i'm going to paste in
some code here and i'll even i'll zoom
in just a little bit more so
this is how to create the most basic
flask app you can create and so you're
importing flask the app is going to be
flasked with the name
and uh so this is how you create a route
in flask you do that the at app that's
the app here
and then the route is just going to be
the default route slash
and this is going to
it's going to basically just when you go
to this route with just a slash at the
end it's going to run this function it's
going to return hello world
and so let's just test this out right
now i'm going to save this and then i'm
going to
and then i'm going to create a new
terminal window
and then i'm going to just do
vnv
slash ben slash
flask
run
okay it's giving me a url to go to so i
will just control click here
okay and here it is i'm going to zoom in
here and so it just says hello
world
okay so we've created a flask app
and we've verified that flask is working
correctly
okay back in vs code i'm going to
make my terminal get a little smaller
here
actually i'll just stop the app for now
until we've made some more adjustments
to our
or a code
and
i'm going to
actually paste in some all new code here
now check i'm going to be pasting in a
lot of code in this tutorial
you probably don't want to wait around
as i type in every single thing in here
so i'm going to be pasting in some code
and then i'm going to be explaining what
the different parts do so if you check
in the description you can get a link to
all the code that we are using in this
tutorial
so you can see uh first we're importing
os this is going to allow us to get an
environment variable later and then
where we are
importing we're getting we're getting
flask because this we're using making a
flask app just like before
now here is where we are importing the
plumi automation framework this is what
i discussed earlier
so we're importing plume's automation
framework as a variable called auto
then in the ensure
plugins function we get access to the
local workspace
a and a and this is something specific
to pollumi a workspace is the execution
context containing a single plumi
project
workspaces are used to manage the
execution environment they provide
various utilities such as plug-in
installation environment configuration
and creation deletion and listing of
stacks
now here we have the ws dot install
plugins because we are deploying aws
resources in this tutorial we must
install the aws provider plugin within
the workspace so that the plumi program
will have available during execution
and then we have the create app function
this is what flask will run when we
start the flask app
we must first ensure plugins we run this
function here
and then create the flask app now this
is very similar to what we saw in our
example flask app that we just tested
before i put in this code app equals
flask
now this app.config.from
mapping this is also something specific
to flask not pollumi
this function is used by flask to set
some default configurations that the app
will use
this will not be a production ready app
but if you ever deploy a flask app make
sure to change the secret key i just
have a secret you can basically have
this anything
you want the other variables are used by
polumi
so we have the project name of
herokul
ii i had updated this at first it was
hero cool because
that's what it was originally going to
be called but remember we called it hero
cool 2. so it's this has been updated
hero cool 2. you may want to use heroku
depending on what you called if you're
following along
and then we get the environment variable
the pluma organization we get this this
environment variable that's why we
imported os above
now the rest of this file is common to
flask apps we set the default route here
and just with this slash this is just
like the example we already showed but
now we are also setting the http method
this is for get requests
now you probably already know about http
methods and requests but a get request
is one of the most common requests when
you're getting
information
to your web browser so we are getting
the index.html file it's going to return
this template that index the html
template
this is an html file that we still have
to create and basically it's going to
render this file to the browser when
someone goes to this route
and then we have this here
the file is going to import the sites
and virtual machines files which we
still have to create
and it registers them as a blueprint
register blueprint
a blueprint in flask is a way to
organize a group of related views and
other code
rather than registering views and other
code directly with an application
they're registered with a blueprint
then the blueprint is registered with
the application when it is available in
the factory function
basically we're using blueprints so we
can define additional routes for our web
app in other files
it's all just about being able to create
some routes and these other files so
speaking of other files let's create
some so i'm going to create a directory
called template so let's click the new
directory and this is going to be called
templates
and then i'm going to create a file
called index.html
and then i'll paste in some code here
here's index.html again you can get all
this code at the link in the description
i won't go into too much detail about
this code it's basic html but anything
inside curly braces
like uh this block content this is in
curly braces here yeah this is in curly
braces basically anything inside the
curly braces is an expression that will
be output to the final document
flask uses the jinja template library to
render
templates so we can use the curly braces
the jinja templates
to dynamically render things like for
instance soon we're going to use it to
dynamically render a list of the sites
and virtual machines that the user has
created
and then we can also access variables
that we create in the python code we can
then put the the variables in these
curly braces to make them appear on in
our in our website in the front end of
our website
and you can see we can get specific urls
so it's getting the url for this
sites.list sites now this is something
we're going to create in our python file
we're going to create a list sites
function
and this is going to be a specific route
that we set up in our python file and
this url4 function will be able to get
that
that url basically
so next let's create a new file you can
already see that this extends base.html
so there should be a
when it displays it's going to display
is the base.html is going to come before
the rest of this content so i'll save
this and i'm going to create this new
file and it's going to be called
base.html
okay i'm going to paste in this yeah so
this is going to have a header and it's
going to have another container that's
going to have different flashed messages
so
our our app is going to be able to flash
up alerts and messages to to the user
and that's going to be at the all this
is going to be at the top of every
page in our website
so i'll just save that
and now we're going to pretty quickly
create the rest of our html templates
and then we'll create the
python files that do the real heavy
lifting in our app
and we'll go much slower through the
python files the python files are going
to be what's actually
using pollumi to
create the different resources on aws
so we're gonna inside this templates
folder i'm going to create two more
directories i'm going to create the
sites directory
and i'm going to create the virtual
machines
[Music]
directory
oh
these weren't supposed to be within each
other
so i move that
okay so they're both in the same root
level
and each of these are going to have the
same three files they're going to have
an index.html file
a
create.html file
and an
update.html file and the same for
virtual machines
and we'll paste in stuff here i want to
kind of point out some things here so
it's going to start with the base html
it's going to have this
navigation
here but the real thing we want to look
at
is um
it's going to the real thing we want to
look at is going it's going to take
information from our python code that we
still have to write to have to write
specifically there's going to be a
list called sites
if there's no sites it's just going to
say no websites are currently
deployed create one to get started and
then the url for sites.createsite which
will go to
this create.html and it's going to allow
people to create a site
but then if if there are sites it's
going to loop this for site and sites
and it's going to add this free site so
you can see it's
getting the the url for the site and the
the name for the site
and
it's
getting a url to delete the site and to
update the slides and you can see the id
is the site name
the site name so it's getting all this
information
from
the the site's
list that we are going to create in
python and this site is actually going
to
this list of sites is going to come
right from paloomi we're going to use
polumi to get this list of sites that
have been created on aws
to show on this index page
and then yeah then there's the console
url you'll see what all this is in a
minute
so i'm not going to talk too much about
these other ones it's pretty
self-explanatory it's just basic html
all the functionality comes on the
python end so that's what we're going to
really focus on talking about
now the create and update are are very
similar it's it's
doing basically similar things except
update will have some information
already filled in
and then i'm just going to add this code
for the virtual me machines files which
is just like for the sites except it's
going to be showing information about
the virtual machines
so here
it's going to like if if there are if
there's no vms no virtual machines are
currently deployed but if there are vms
so it's going to be able to
have a link to delete the vm
update the vm
and here it's giving a command to
ssh into the virtual machine
and we are going to actually try this
out later after we create a virtual
machine with this app we're going to ssh
into it and it's always going to start
with this same
line
and then it's going to have
the the dns name it's getting see where
the curly braces so it's getting that
directly from
um
from
the python side where we've stored the
dns name for each virtual machine
okay now we'll do the crate there's
nothing too fancy in the crate it's just
a web form to insert certain information
for our virtual machine and then we have
the update one
and this is to update information the
virtual machine now i'm just going to
make sure all these files are saved and
actually i'm going to close some of
these
we're not really going to need to go
back into these views
these templates i mean
now it's time to create the
functionality of our heroku clone using
python so the app.pi file imports from
these files that we still have to create
so in the same directory as app.pi let's
create
sites.pi
so
new file
sites.pi
so now that we got the sites.pi i'm
going to paste in some code here
and these are all just the basic imports
that we need for flask and pollumi
including importing the automation
framework right here
and then we import
s3 from plumy
aws to interact with aws and create an
s3 bucket
and then this bp equals blueprint
we see the url prefixes slash sites
so
we are going to be defining
what happens when people go to the url
slash sites
now i'm going to paste in some more code
and then describe what it does here
so here's a new function create plumi
program
and it's going to take a parameter
which is going to be a string
content so on the front end of this web
app that we're creating this hero cool
people can create a website they can
deploy a website by inputting the html
that makes up the website
the html that the that the users put
into the web form becomes this content
and gets passed on to this create plumi
program function
later we're going to be creating some
routes and functions that call this
create plummy program
function and pass in
the html text that's going to become the
content of the website that users are
trying to create
so this function defines our plumi s3
static website in terms of the content
that the caller passes in
it will allow us to dynamically deploy
websites based on defined values from
the post body
so if we go in here we can see that
first we're creating a bucket and
exposing a website index document
and then we're going to write the
index.html into the site bucket so we
have s so oh and again the s3 this is
this is part of paloomy this is part of
plummy to create s3 bucket and we're
creating the bucket object
and
the bucket the id is the sitebucket.id
which is going to be come from
the bucket that we created up here the
content is the index content which is
what the user passed in as the html of
the file
then we have the key and the content
type
and then we are going to set the access
policy for the bucket so all objects are
readable
now the way this gets set is specific to
aws
so
that's where all this is coming from
like this date is actually
specific to aws that we have to pass in
for this
and
you'll be able so depending on what
you're going to do you just have to look
up what information
you need for a bws to create a bucket
and then finally we are going to export
the website url so
the purpose of this
pollumi.export command
that that you see here is to export a
named stack output
exported values are attached to the
program's stack resource
later we will see how we can access this
data that's being exported
it's kind of like an environment
variable so this is the key it's like a
key value pair the key is the website
url the value is
sitebucket.website endpoint this is
going to be the url that we get directly
from aws after deploying this site to
the s3 bucket
and then the website content this is
just the the the content the the html of
the website that we get here
so far nothing is calling this function
so at this point let's create url
endpoints that can be used to call that
function we just created
to create websites
so first
we will create a
may push this but this is a new route so
at slash new so first is going to be
slash sites
and then after the at the end of slash
sites is slash new
and this will respond to both get and
post requests
so
first we're going to check if it's a
post request
and let's just go down to see what
happens if it's a get request if it's a
get request
it's going to return render the template
sites slash create
the create.html
but if it's a post request that means
the the user has already went has
already done the get request they filled
in the form and now they're sending data
to the same url and this is what we're
going to do with that now you see this
request.form.get
well we got request that's just part of
flask and this is part of
oh where'd it go
this is how we access the information
that's sent with the form
and the information is different key
value pairs so the user will have put in
the site id
into the form and now we're getting that
and we're setting it to be the stack
name and then the user will have put in
a file url possibly maybe not so the way
it works the user can
put in the file url which is the the url
they want to upload to the s3 bucket
or
they can type in the html and that's
going to be the site content so first
we're going to get the fire url if there
is a file url then we'll set the site
content to now request
dot get
this is going to be doing a an http
request
to whatever url that the person passed
in and getting the text
or
we're just going to get whatever the
user typed into the site content
and then we're going to define a
function plummy program where we're
going to call this function here the
uh create plummy program function
and we pass in the site content the
string of the site content so that's how
we actually create the website
but this function hasn't been called yet
because we're going to do that within
this try catch block
so a try catch this is just if you're
not familiar if you don't know a lot
about python it's just an error handling
thing so we try the code in here and if
there's an error
then it's going to
do what's down here
so the first thing that's going to
happen says create a new stack
generating our plumi program on the fly
from the post body
so you can see auto is the automation
framework auto dot create stack
as a reminder every plumi program is
deployed to a stack
a stack is an isolated independently
configurable instance of a pollumi
program
in this code the stack name is based on
the id
that the user types into the form
so remember stack name right here was
the id
and then we got the project name
and then the plumi program
and pulling me program is this which
uses pollumi to create the website on
aws
now it's not going to run the program
until we get down here
stack dot up
if you had the if you're on the plumy
cli you would do
plumey up
but first we're going to make sure we
have the correct way we can set the aws
region now there would already be one as
default but you could you could set a
different aws region here
and then we deploy
so stack that up and then it's going to
it says on output print so this is going
to
print all the output so in the terminal
and then
we have a flash so this is going to
flash up on the website successfully
created site
or it may flash up an error
so this stacked up let's just i'm going
to talk a little bit more about that
because once the stack is created we can
execute commands against the stack
including update preview refresh destroy
import and export so stacked up up is to
update the stack
and then you can pass in the a callback
which i already discussed which is going
to
print to the standard output
okay i'm going to add a new section of
code
which will discuss
this is going to be a new route this is
just to the
the root route the slash but it's not
just slash because it's still going to
take into account the sites so if you
just go to slash site slash it's going
to list all the sites this is a get
request
and it's going to so this variable right
here sites it's a list this is what's
going to be passed into our template our
front end once it's full of sites it
will be passed in and then it can
display the list of sites
we're going to get the org name and the
project name
and then it's going to try this and
remember if it's an error we'll just go
down to this accept here
but the first thing it's going to do
is
to get the automation framework that
local workspace
a workspace is the execution context
containing a single plummy project a
program and multiple stacks
so here we're getting access to the
workspace
and then we are passing in the project
name of the workspace
then we have list stacks
so this just gives us access to the
stack name
so we also so that all stacks is just
going to be the the names of all the
stacks so now we have to get access to
the specific
stacks
so
that's why we do auto dot select stack
and we pass in the stack we're trying to
get stack dot name
and the project name
and then whenever you do select stack
you can pass in a program but we don't
want the program to do anything so
that's why it's just lambda none so
select select stack is very similar if
we scroll up here to
create stack so create stacked and
select stack have similar parameters so
in this case the program was to run this
pollumi program but when we're selecting
the stack we're not going to run any
program or anything that's why
we just have a
basically a blank function here
and
out
equals select outputs so remember when
we initially created it up here we
exported things so the outputs are going
to actually just be this information so
we're getting the website url and the
website content for each item basically
each website
and once we get the information for if
the website url isn't out then we'll
append
this information to the sites remember
this is what's being passed to our front
end this the name stack.name the url
so it's going to be
the the website url
and then the console url so console url
this just means where we can access
information about this on the plumy
website
that's one great thing about polumi is
that you can get information about your
application through the command line and
through different ways through your
program but you can also go to the plumi
website every time you're you're
creating a stack every time we're
creating a site or virtual machine we
can go to the plumi website to get
information about that
about that whatever resource we created
so i'll show you that later when when we
try out this program that we're making
and then if there's an exception we will
flash this to the person
and then we we're going to return this
we're going to render the template
and it's the index.html template and
we're going to pass in
sites equals sites so when we under
under the template and pass in the sites
uh that means if you remember we'll just
look at that really quick but if we go
to the index it's
looking for each site in that list to
display
okay i'm going to save that and we're
going to add a little bit more to this
file
so i'm going to paste this in
and i'm going to talk about this
so this is the update route first it's
going to be the id of the site
slash update and this can be a get
request or a post request
so first it's going to
receive the id
into this function here and we're going
to store it as the stack name
so if it's a post request first let's
see what happens if it's a get request
so if it's a get request it's going to
render this template
update.html because the person wants to
update it and then once it actually is
updated it's a post request
and it's going to do this now this is
going to look very similar to our the
previous function
when when someone creates a
new site it's very similar to when
they're updating the site so we get the
this is all the same the fire file url
first we get the site
content we have the plumi program
we have the select stack now this is all
pretty much the same
we do stack that up
we do stack to up to update it one good
thing about updating with pollumi it's
going to see what's changed and only
update those things i'm not going to
just update everything it's going to
only update whatever has changed so even
though we're putting all this
thing all this stuff here it's only
going to figure out what changed and
update that
and then we're going to flash
successfully updated we have the error
and then it's going to
redirect to sites.list sites which was
just our slash so not the update the the
index
but then this is what happens if it's a
get request first we're going to get the
stack and then the stack that outputs so
we can get the website content
and then the website content will be
used when we render the template because
that's what we want the the content of
the website to show in the
in the update section so users can see
what they're updating and there's only
one more section to this file which is
the delete route so i'm going to paste
in this here now this is very
straightforward
so
if the
the
the route is the id slash delete it's a
post
and there's not even any get request
here that so there's no page for
deleting you just click the delete
button and it's going to
delete
so we get the the so we have the stack
name we're going to first wait to select
the stack then stack dot destroy
so previously we just
stacked that up to update it but here
we're going to destroy
and then remove the stack
and this
is a
cool thing about pollumi
just doing stack dot destroy
it's automatically going to
delete the resource on aws
so whether
it's an s3 bucket whether it's a virtual
machine or whatever resource that we
create on aws just doing stack dot
destroy
will delete it
so it's not going to charge you any
money anymore because it's just
completely
deleted off of aws
and then it's going to flash the message
and then
there's a few possible exceptions that
could happen and then it's just going to
redirect to the list of sites
okay this file is done and there's
really just one more file to create
which is kind of similar to this file
it's those the same one but for virtual
machines so i am going to go up here to
new file
and this is going to be called
virtual
machines
dot pi
now this time i'm just going to paste in
the whole thing
and they're going to go through it it's
a little bit longer but there's so much
similarities we're not going to have to
go through everything
because the automation framework makes
working with different types of
resources very similar
it's not exactly the same because aws is
going to require different information
when you create different types of
resources
but the whole top section is basically
the same now here we have instance types
because when you're creating a virtual
machine on aws you have to choose
what type of instance you're going to
use for your virtual machine and
in reality there's way more options on
aws
than these three but for this example
we're going to give the user three
different options but you could easily
add more to this list here
and so here we're going to create the
program
and right now the only thing that the
user will be able to choose is the
instance type or you could make it so a
user could create could
do could choose other options
so here
this is the pollumi
library but all this information is
specific to aws
so when you're creating a virtual
machine you're going to first have to
get access to the ami
and then we have specific information in
here that's specific to aws and we also
need the security group
and so we specify this and it's going
this is how we're going to enable ssh
access because we want to build ssh into
our virtual machine which we will
actually do i'll show you how to do that
once we get this all set up
now this is going to be something that's
different with the virtual machine than
the
the website hosted on s3
we are going to have a key
we're going to have a pry a public
private key pair
this is going to basically provide
authentication when we want to access
the virtual machine to make it so only
the person who created the virtual
machine can access it and not just
anybody can get into it
when we're creating the virtual machine
on aws we must give a public key then in
order to access the vm you have to have
the private key so what this is doing
here is getting the public key
information
from our local file system so we're
getting the the path and it's just
accessing
this path the home path
to access the public key on the file
system now this is a file and we're
going to actually have to make sure we
have created this file so when this goes
to access it it's already there
now this this
directory this directory structure
is generally the same on both mac and
windows and linux so whatever operating
system you have this path is
this should work no matter what
operating system you have and the way
that we're going to create the key value
pair it puts it into the same
directory basically no matter what
operating system you have
so this is something that when you're
creating the virtual machine through the
web interface you're going to have to
put in the string of characters which is
your public key
and then later when you ssh into the
virtual machine you have to make sure
you have the private key on your
computer so it can
validate that you are the person who
owns this virtual machine
and i'll be showing you how to do all
that in just a little bit
but it's going to
strip all the white space from the
public key
it's going to print the public key
remember public keys can be
the public knowledge anybody can know
your public key but you don't want
anybody to know your private key
and we're going to create a key pair and
this is specific to aws how this is
created
and then we are going to have to get the
the server
and you can see we're passing in the
security group the key pair the instance
type and the ami this is all stuff that
we created earlier
and then it's going to do a bunch of
exports the instance type public key
public ip and public dns and this is the
information that we're going to be able
to use to access it through ssh
okay now
this was just the function we just have
to make the routes to use the function
so just like before we have the new
route
we are going to
get the the form data the form that is
going to have the id which is just
something that a user makes up and it's
going to become the stack name
someone the user is going to enter the
key the public key which is now going to
be the key data
and then they're going to choose an
instance type and remember the instance
type is going to be one of these three
options that is going to be
basically going to be a drop down menu
on the front end and that's going to be
stored as instance type
and then with the creep
fluid program it passes in the key data
and the instance type
and then the rest of this is very
similar where we create the stack
and then we
configure it and then stack that up
and then on success
on not success then it's going to
list the vms again
and then
this current app.logger this is just
going to make sure
information is
we'll just log this information of the
instance types
now
if someone did a get request it's going
to go to the create.html the everything
else was the post request and when it
does the create the html it's going to
pass in
some data the instance types because
this is going to become a drop down menu
on in
in the index the
create.html file
and the current instance type is none
and then we have the this is just where
it lists all the the vms because it's
just slash it's a get request and it's
going to be very similar to what we've
already looked at uh let's see what's
new the only
real
new thing in this compared to what we
already looked yeah in the sites is
what's being
outputted what i mean what's going to be
in the list but you get the dna dns name
but everything else is basically the
same
and then to update well update is going
to be very similar to when you're
creating something new
i guess the only really the only
difference when you're updating it
is that when this renders update.html
it's going to have a current instance
type whereas when you're creating a new
one there was no current instance type
there's also we already have the public
key the stack name and the instance
types and then we have delete now this
is going to be
almost exactly the same as the sites one
because we just have to get access to
the stack
and destroy it
and it's going to completely destroy the
virtual machine
from
amazon.aws
now this can be super helpful because if
you've done any work on aws
especially if you're just learning you
may find out the hard way that
if you turn on things on aws and forget
to turn them off
it can start charging you a lot of money
but when you just do stack that destroy
well that will just delete everything
and you will no longer be charged the
money anymore so even with this example
it's gonna cost us a little bit of money
but just a few cents as long as you
destroy it right away
okay i'm going to save this
and now i'm going to show you how to set
up your key value pair
there is a program called ssh keygen and
this is on both
mac and windows
so
you may already have it on your computer
if not you can just look up sss keygen
on
just search for it and find out how to
get it installed but we're just going to
run this sss keygen
program to create a new key private
public
key pair so i'm going to type in down to
my terminal here
ssh
key
gen
and
dash m and i'm going to make of the type
pim
and this is the type that you need to
use for aws and i'm just going to press
enter
and then enter file was to save the key
now i'm just going to
do the default and you
and then you're probably going to want
to use a passphrase here
[Music]
okay now i've created it
now we're going to go to that directory
just to make sure we have it in there so
i'm going to
change to the directory
[Music]
[Music]
now this is the file we just created but
you're gonna have to make sure it has a
a dot pm
pem extension i already have this
because i already created one with a dot
pem
extension so you're going to want to
rename this
now it's different depending on what
kind of operating use system you have
but one way to to
rename it on mac and
is just mv
you just put in the the name here
and then mv means move so i'm moving it
from one name to the other name so i'm
going to just put rsa.pem
so on windows and you could basically do
the same thing but instead of doing mv
for move you're going to type in rename
so rename you're going to put the first
file and then what do you what you want
to be
so this is our public key
so if you remember our program we'll try
to get that public key file
but you can also enter it as your key
data so you can either open up that file
and copy the key and then paste it into
our web interface or if you don't just
if you just don't put anything it will
try to get that information
on its own
okay now let's let me just get back into
our other directory
[Music]
and then we're going to run our flask
app i'm going to start a little
differently so i can put in some
environment variables first
so see i'm putting in the the port
the environment the pluma organization
and then i'm going to run
okay it's time to test this out
okay this is looking good so far except
we still need to create our css files so
let's go back and make sure we get our
our css in there so it looks a little
nicer than this but we do know that it
is seems to be working so far
so actually just pasted in these files
here static and this is just bootstrap
we're just using basic bootstrap
for our css
we're just trying to make it simple here
so let's go back over and refresh
okay this is looking good i'm gonna zoom
out a little bit
okay so
hero cool
and we can
either create a static website or a
virtual machine
so let's
test to see if everything works i'm
going to click get started
okay no websites are currently deployed
create one to get started
so here is where we can create a name
and i'm going to just call it hello
world
and the name there can't be any spaces
the way that we created this so the file
url well i'm not going to have a file
url i'm going to create some content so
i'm going to do hello and i'm going to
make put in some html here so we can
test to see if that works
world
and then i'm going to click create
and look at this successfully create
site hello world
now this it could actually take a while
to create the site especially if it's
the first one
so it you're just gonna have to kind of
wait a while to see just for it to
finally kind of pop up like this
and so let's test a few things first of
all i'm going to just click this
and it's going to open the url now let
me zoom in so you can see it hello world
and we see it has bold and you can see
this url it's right on
s3
s3 desk website dash us is one amazon
ews.com so we have this website on here
and if i click view in console well
before i do that let's go back to our
visual studio code
and you can see
it's
outputted website content website url
resources it created four resources so
we can see right in here that it
actually created the resources
and i'm going to try viewing on console
here
this is opening right on pallumi
and then if you're signed in then you
can get to here look it's so it's
beaucon slash hero hero cool 2
slash hello world
let me zoom in a little bit here
and then we can see the website content
we can see the website url and then we
can see more information like
configuration
secrets management we got some tags here
and we can see all this information
about our site here
and then with resources we can see
additional information about the
the the bucket is you what bucket is
used index the policy
and then it's even going to give us
information about how to destroy things
and change things but we don't need to
do any of that because
we can do all that from our web
interface
we're going to actually try editing and
deleting this but before i want to show
it to you on
amazon aws now
the great thing about this is you never
really would need to check on amazon aws
but i would just show you what it looks
like on there
okay now i'm on my amazon
aws account i'm on the s3 section and
you can see the buckets and you can see
right here here is the bucket we just
created it's showing the index file here
and it's showing here's the url the url
that we were given that go that you can
use to access this file if i go and i'm
going to just go back over here to show
this here
now i'm going to go back to our web app
our hero cool
and i'm going to
first let's try a few things i'm going
to edit it and then i'm going to delete
it so first i'm going to check to see if
edit works
and
we are going to put this all in an h1
tag
now just click
update
and it's successfully updated
now i'm going to click here and let me
refresh oh no i don't have to refresh
this is with the
h1 tag so that's why it's all way bigger
than before and with h1
bold really doesn't do anything
so that's why there's not no difference
between hello and world
so now i'm going to delete this resource
site hello world successfully deleted
and then if we go if we go back into the
terminal here we can see that oh
it's going it's showing what it's doing
it's it's going through and deleting all
these things it's selling the bucket
policy the bucket
object
the
the s3 bucket and the stack
it's deleting all of this stuff anything
that was associated with it it just
deletes
and if i go and refresh here on my
am s3 page oh this bucket is no longer
found it's now no longer in the bucket
list it's completely deleted off amazon
aws
now i'm going to try creating another
one this time i'm going to use a file
url this is just a game that i found on
github so i
i'm going to see it's a
i just clicked on the raw file and we're
just going to put in this url to see if
it works i'm going to call it a snake
and then i'm going to create
successfully created so if i click here
and now i'm playing
snake
i just put in that url
and i can play this game cool
[Music]
so i'm just going to close this for now
and let's see what happens if i click
edit
well now
we don't just have the url here we have
all the code that it got from the url
and now we can make any changes we want
like uh what if we want to change the
the canvas let's change how big this is
instead of 400 by 400 i'm gonna put a
thousand by a thousand
and update that
okay if i click here
and now wow this is a really big
this game is going to be really easy to
not hit myself now
[Music]
i think maybe the apples still are all
going to be in this one little corner
[Music]
but i can go really far away so i was
able to update the code
right from there
okay and just so you can see what it
looks like if you have multiple ones we
can call this test
and test
and i'm just going to hit create
so now we have two here
and you can see it creates on
amazon it creates a bucket for each
for each one that we create there's a
new bucket for each website
and then if i click view and console
you can see we can go back here and we
can see snake and
test
and then here we can even see
for the snake when we can see all the
code
okay let's go back to here
and now we're gonna create a virtual
machine
create a virtual machine
and this is going to be called
potato
and then you can choose your instance
type
i'll just do c3.large
and then i can
get the text of my public key and paste
it here but let's see what happens if i
don't even do that if i just click
create
if i go back into my terminal we can see
it actually found my public key
automatically
and it's now creating it now i could
have
opened up that public key file in a text
editor and copied this and then paste it
into that text box
but this way is even easier
and now it says it's done creating let's
go back over here and it successfully
created the vm potato
now let's find in aws it's not going to
be under s3
it should be under ec2
okay so if i go over here
we can see that this one is running
it's initializing right now
and then here we can see more
information about our virtual machine
but i'm going to get this here and i'm
going to try
connecting it to it through ssh
so i'm going to copy that
now i'm back in my
terminal that's not in vs code and it's
going to paste in
this url here
and you can see it's accessing our dot
pem file
are you sure you want to continue
yes
and then the passphrase that we created
that i created when i was creating that
file
[Music]
and i'm in i'm now inside the virtual
machine i can
uh
change directories
and you can see that
see i can see all these directories
right in this virtual machines i can now
actually use this to create a web server
or do anything i want with this linux
box
and
you can do it right through your
terminal
now the cost of these virtual machines
adds up much quicker than the cost of
the sites so i'm going to go ahead and
delete this
and
all these actions can take some time but
if you want one you can always look in
the console to see what's happening see
it's still it's deleting this right now
it can take some time because it's
it's deleting everything associated with
the virtual machine from aws and from
our records on pollumi
okay it just deleted everything
so
let's try a few things
first look it says the connection was
closed closed by remote host i didn't
even have to do anything
[Music]
it says successfully deleted
and then if i go to my instances
it's now saying instant state
terminated
okay so now i'm not gonna pay any more
money for this instance
so we just created a very simplified
version of heroku and you can use the
same principles and concepts to create
applications that provision all sorts of
other resources and like i mentioned you
can do it with a bunch of other
programming languages and cloud service
providers to show you how it would work
with different programming languages i'm
now going to show you how to write a
simple javascript program that will
provision a web app on aws this won't
have any front end but you'll be able to
see how the code is very similar to the
python code this is the type of thing
that could be helpful if you're involved
with platform engineering
okay i'm in vs code
and this time i'm going to be using
node.js and javascript instead of python
like i just said there's not going to be
any front end to this program we're
going to deploy an inline paloomy
program that will create a static
website using the automation api
so it's going to be a little different
but you'll definitely see a lot of
similarities to what we just did with
python
so first let's start our project just
with an npm
init
and this is just going to we're just
going to use all these default settings
here
and this is just going to create a
package.json file so we can install some
dependencies
so first
we're going to be connecting the aws
with pollumi so let's do mpm
install
at paloomi slash aws
so this will help us to connect to aws
with our javascript program now we're
going to install one more npm init
install or npm install
at pollumi slash pollumi
so this is just going to be the the
basic
pollumi program
okay we got that done and i can create
my file
and this is gonna be index.js
okay just like with the python section
i'm gonna paste in some code and then
explain what it all does
and there'll be a link to the code in
the description so let me go back up to
the top and we're first going to
require the the plumi libraries that we
just installed the bloomy slash bloomies
plummy slash aws so that's the
automation framework
and aws
and then we need this process because
we're going to
see if there's any arguments when the
program is called now this we're going
to make this program
so we can call it from the command line
and it's normally going to create a
website but we want to make it so if we
want we can also destroy the website
from aws so that's why we're allowing
the
the user to put in an argument destroy
after the the program name when they're
running the program so that's what this
it does it figure out figures out if
this is going to be destroying the
website if not it's going to be creating
the website so let's go over here
and
so let me just show you kind of the
whole thing at a glance really quick we
have this run program and we have this
whole run program and at the end
we
run the program we just call that
function
and then we catch if there's any errors
so let's see what's in that function
well the first thing in this function
is our plumi program
so
this
this plumey program is in the inline
function format
which is just a slightly different than
than what we saw with the python
so unlike a traditional plumi program
inline functions don't require a
separate package on disk
so we won't need a plumi.eml file inline
programs are just functions
and
they can be
in they can also be imported from
another package but in this case we are
creating it right in this file here so
this so this first section we are
defining the plumi program that we want
to run as a function within the overall
program
and it looks just like a standard pluma
program
so
we create the site bucket which is very
similar to what we saw in the python
code
and
this is just
just like that we're creating the site
bucket and we're
specifying the index document
and then
this is
the the html that we're going to put
into the site now remember in python we
had the user supply this information but
in this case we're just putting it right
in the program
and then we are writing the index file
into the site bucket so that's the index
content is the content and the buck is
one the one we already defined up there
and so you should see a lot of
similarities with the python code
and then we're creating the s3 bucket
policy to allow people to read
everything in there so this date again
is just right from the aws all this
information is what we have to what aws
needs to say that anybody can access the
files in the bucket which are in our
case are the is the index.html file
and then we refer to the bucket right
here
okay so here's where we actually create
the policy and we're going to apply
what we created right up here
and then we are going to return the uh
basically like a key value pair the
website url is going to be
the website endpoint which we're going
to need to be able to access the website
and the website url is just going to be
the website endpoint which will need to
access the website
and now we're going to be associating it
with a stack
so as with existing plumey programs we
need to associate this plumi program
with a stack
the automation api provides methods to
create or select stacks and
their in javascript is just like
very similar to the what it's like in
python
so
this is going to
do the crate
here create or select stack
so it's either going to create a new one
or if it already exists
it's going to select the stack it would
already exist if we're trying to destroy
it so the first time we run this program
is creating it if we run the program
again with the destroy then it's going
to
select the stack that already exists
and
just like with the python code we are
going to install the aws plugin we're
going to set this configuration and
there could be a default configuration
that's already been set up but if not
it's going to use this one
with the aws region
and then we're just going to refresh the
stack
and you can see what it does right on
here it compares the current stacks
resource state with the state known to
exist in the actual cloud provider and
then any such changes are adapted into
the current stack
and both of these here
are configuring the aws plugin the plumy
aws plugin
and we're just using the stack object to
set the region and the provider
okay and if we go down this is what we
already talked about if
the destroy argument has been passed in
we'll do stack dot destroy which will
destroy everything
uh the on blooming and also destroy
everything on aws so anything that's
been created on aws will be destroyed
and then the program will exit here but
if it doesn't get destroyed we'll go
down to
this
so await stack dot up
up is update
and we are choosing to have a callback
which is going to the standard output
and doing console.info so it's
outputting everything to the standard
output
but you can do other things with this
callback function
so you could choose to take different
actions if there were no resources
updated for example
or
you could use the stack outputs to drive
another prelumi program within the same
automation program so that's
with having the callback function it
opens up a lot of possibilities to what
you can do after this update takes place
and then it's just going to log the url
that we've set way up here
so then we can go to the url
and then it's going but then then that's
the end of that function and here we run
the function
so let's test this out i'm going to save
this
and then i'm just going to do node
index.js
and here's the website url
so i can just copy this and then i'll go
to in the web browser
okay here it is in the web browser hello
world and you can see it even says hello
s3 up here because we set the title of
the page
and you can see it's hosted on amazon
aws
okay now i'm going to run this program
again node index.js but this time i'm
going to pass in an argument destroy
let me just confirm that is what are yep
destroy so if i pass in destroy
and you can see everything's being
deleted we have four resources that were
deleted
the s3 website bucket the bucket policy
the bucket object
the node here
okay they've been deleted
and then you can also run another
command to remove the stack completely
now this in the python file we actually
did run that command
and here we didn't but we can
always run that manually and then if we
go and refresh on the page
404 not found
so i hope that gave you a good sense of
how the javascript and the python works
and the similarities and the differences
and there you have it our javascript
program is able to provision
infrastructure just like our python
program
so i hope you can take these concepts
and this knowledge and start applying it
to your own projects well thanks for
watching
foreign